ich habe ein bisschen überspitzt aber
ich glaube dass es ganz gut allen leuten
fällt auf dass es immer teurer wird und
was mich dabei besonders ärgert ist
nicht ich halt sache dass das so ist das
macht uns einen sorge sondern die
tatsache dass wie immer seltener davon
lesen warum das so ist also ja wie das
haben eine krise durch die erste nicola
krise war auch eine auf hausgemacht oder
unausweichlich darum geht es am ende
nicht müssen sie bewältigen und tatsache
ist dass der ukraine krieg so schlimme
ist und so betroffene uns machen sollte
und so oft über ihn diskutieren nicht
die ursache für unsere massiv steigende
preise sind wir hatten inflationssorgen
zu beginn des jahres und wir haben ein
geldmengenwachstum seit der euro-krise
seit 2008 also auch schon 20 jahre her
von 15 jahre her von einer also in einer
menge wir haben eine verdreifachung des
der geldmenge seit beginn der
euro-einführung herr bosbach wird sich
erinnern dass er zu denjenigen gehört
die den euro-rettungsschirm damals
abgelehnt habe und schwer unter beschuss
stand in der union recht verhalten hilft
einem nicht das wissen wir alle die
frage ist was tun wir jetzt und damit
wir herausfinden können was wir tun
müssen wir die ursachen geben und die
ursachen sind dass wir einen währungs
schuhe anhaben der uns in europa
unterschiedlich passt und tatsache ist
dass wir diese inflation nicht loswerden
wenn der ukraine krieg vorbei sein
sollte egal in wie vielen monaten oder
jahren das der fall sein sollte der euro
ist im eimer und wir werden uns
überlegen müssen wie wir mit diesem
problem umgehen und ich sehe derzeit
leider ganz ganz wenige politiker keine
die in funktionen sind die willens oder
in der lage wären den bürgern darüber
reinen wein einzuschenken und ich dachte
es sind eigentlich wenn man krisen
bewältigen möchte dann hilft es nicht um
den heißen brei herumzureden dann muss
irgendwann jemand mal den hintern in der
hose haben und sagen da gibt es ein
problem das gibt es auch nicht erst seit
heute das gibt es genau ihm seit der
cholera die meisten kritiker die die
entscheidung getroffen haben sind auch
nicht mehr man insofern wäre es ein
guter zeitpunkt zu sagen wir müssen
etwas gegen diese instabil werden weil
er sonst auf soziale unruhen inflation
geldentwertung und ein verlust des
vertrauens in einen wirtschaftsstandort
zu laufen der seinesgleichen sucht wir
haben de facto bei der währung
italienische verhältnisse und das nicht
erst seit heute und wenn wir jetzt zu
tun als clip mehr auslaufen lassen dann
werden wir erleben dass die sozialen
spannungen auch möglicherweise die
gefahr vor weiterem extremismus nicht
nur in anderen teilen europas sondern
auch in deutschland zunehmen was man hat
eben sie jetzt hier schon so viel lob
programm von herr jörg sondern hätte
gesagt
was wenn sie denn jetzt tun wenn sie
kanzler werden das ist sachlich nicht
wünsche
dieser regierung das ist aufgabe der
europäischen zentralbank ist war die
aufgabe der deutschen bundesbank die
währung stabil zu halten das war die
aufgabe der europäischen zentralbank bis
zur stunde und das unglück nahm in dem
moment seinen lauf als man geglaubt hat
eine überschuldungskrise die euro krise
war im kern eine überschuldungskrise
dadurch lösen zu können indem man immer
höhere kreditrahmen macht das kann nicht
funktionieren
das hört sich jetzt verwegen anders ist
so die schuldenlast griechenland ist
heute trotz schuldenschnitt von über 100
milliarden euro höher als zu dem
zeitpunkt als die krise ausbrach
griechenland hat eine höhere
schuldenlast als damals allerdings
tragen die risiken mittlerweile nur die
europäischen steuerzahler auch nicht
mehr die privaten anlegern ist spricht
darüber keiner dann wurden die zinsen
auf null gesenkt das ist süßes gift du
musst natürlich die schulden tilgen aber
nur fans keine zinsen mehr dafür wir
sprechen hier über hoch verschuldete
länder die zu zeiten der eigenen währung
bei krediten niederstaufen haben 78 19
12 griechenland 14 anlage wenn jetzt ein
bürger fragte ich jetzt ja ich würde
jetzt nicht unterschreiben aber eine
krise damit überhaupt nichts zu tun hat
aber sie wird gerne herangenommen um
alles zu erklären und da und das ist
nicht richtig im warenkorb sind die
energiepreise natürlich ein
nennenswerter faktor die sind deutlich
durchgehend erleben das war natürlich
auch wanderung
randow
rohstoffpreise auch wenn die
lebensmittel auch also ich fürchte die
europäische zentralbank hat nicht mehr
viele instrumente weil wenn sie die
zinsen erhöht und wenn sie die zinsen
erhöht kommen ja die staaten die
frühjahr 78 9 prozent bezahlt haben zu
staatsanleihen in schwierigkeiten wenn
sowohl 2% für staatsanleihen zahlen
müssen ich fürchte noch etwas anderes
dass wir nämlich in eine
lohn-preis-spirale hineinlaufen macht
muss man nichts vor die gewerkschaften
werden aber satte lot forderungen
stellen warum dann mit ihrer mutter habe
einmal nicht noch mehr allein bußen
hinnehmen und mit mir gerade die die
besser von den rufen den anderen
fröhlich zu da müssen wir mal den gürtel
enger schnallen viele kündigen gürtel
überhaupt nicht mehr enger schnallen
deswegen kann nicht verstehen dass die
gewerkschaften sagen aber ordentlichen
schluck aus der pulle dann werden die
arbeitgeber die das bezahlen müssen
versuchen die höheren kosten über höhere
preise umzulegen und dann setzt sich
diese spirale in gang heiter aber
nationale maßnahmen alleine werden wir
nicht eingreifen können wenn sie
erfolgreich sein sollen das gilt auch
für den tank rabatt das ist ja ein
schuss in den ofen kostet viel geld aber
ich habe nicht das gefühl dass die
mineralölkonzerne das weitergeben oder
weitergeben wollen mal gucken was die
ezb macht weil die ecken hat ja auch die
geschicke in der teuer schock auch mit
blick auf die lebensmittel wie prekär
ist denn die lage die ist eigentlich
prekärer als es sich im augenblick noch
anfühlt der euro ist ein problem weil er
ein europäisches währungs konstrukt ist
was so nicht wirklich funktioniert das
andere problem was wir haben ist dass
sowohl amerika als auch europa eine
falsche währungspolitik den letzten
jahren gemacht haben erst die niedrigen
zinsen süßes gift ganz gutes bild es
lohnt sich einfach kredite aufzunehmen
weil man kriegt geld einfach quasi
umsonst gab sogar negativzinsen da sagen
wir selbst finanzminister es ist viel
besser ich nehme einen kredit auf als
dass ich spare weil ich krieg da noch
was oben drauf wenn ich ein kreditnehmer
das problem ist diese entwicklung jetzt
wieder einzubremsen
haben sowohl amerika zu mehreren
milliardenschweren
konjunkturpaketen gegriffen haben also
wieder schulden finanziert geld in den
in die volkswirtschaft gepumpt der keine
wertschöpfung gegenüber steht das haben
wir auch gemacht wir haben über die
korona krise notgedrungen und
richtigerweise versucht das abzufedern
aber auch da aber schulden gemacht
kurzarbeitergeld gezahlt wir kommen von
dem erst jetzt so schnell nicht runter
und wenn wir jetzt die zinsen anziehen
dann wird ein sehr viel höherer
schuldenberg verzinst werden und ich
kann mich noch erinnern bei den letzten
großen schulden jahren hatten wir etwa
42 milliarden schulden die wir also
tilgungen die wir pro jahr zu zahlen
hatten das ist ein ziemlicher brocken da
kannst du viele kitas für bauen die
zahlst du dann nur an die banken und das
wird jetzt langsam zurück kommen und die
volkswirtschaft weiter abwürgen und das
andere was herr bosbach sagte es stimmt
natürlich auch die preise gehen durch
die ukraine krise in die höhe weil
plötzlich verknappung bei weizen oder
anderen rohstoffen da ist ursächlich
aber wir haben durch die korona krise
und nochmal durch diesen krieg wirklich
dramatisch vor augen geführt bekommen
wie schlimm ist wenn wir abhängig von
anderen sind das heißt wir werden die
globalization hieß es bei der
frühjahrstagung des währungsfonds so
schön wir werden die globalisierung ein
stück entkoppeln und wir versuchen
eigene produktion also auch wir werden
versuchen medizinprodukte mehr in
deutschland herzustellen wir werden
elektronik versuchen herzustellen damit
wächst das ist aber alles teurer als
werden wir billige arbeitsmärkte in
asien bespielen und uns von denen
abhängig machen das heißt wir werden
auch da in eine weitere preissteigerung
einlaufen ich glaube man muss
fairerweise sagen dass es herr bosbach
den finger an der richtigen stelle die
wunde gelegt hat es wäre guten hier sind
koppeln könnten aber das was deutschland
mal konnte zu zeiten der d-mark dass wir
nicht nur unabhängige oder eine
vergleichsweise eigene währungspolitik
machen konnten und damit auch kapital
angezogen haben und eine gute
investition jährige preis haben wir in
zweifelsohne aber seid einfach des euro
ist haben wir eine kapitalflucht aus dem
euroraum und diese setzt sich natürlich
fort wenn wir mit dauerhafter inflation
in möglicherweise zweistelliger
größenordnung leben müssen und das ist
eben nichts neues was habe ich
verstanden meint 79 jahre genau wir sind
doch nicht zweiten liga aber wir sind
auf gutem weg dahin und es gibt einen
entscheidenden unterschied zu früheren
jahren mit hoher inflation wir sind
richtige wir sind wir richtig gesagt
wurde bei einer nullzinspolitik und
normalerweise ist die zinspolitik das
einzige was die fed etwas was ich
zentral erhöhen alle die eigene währung
haben erhöhen wir müssen mal schauen wir
haben im euroraum inflationsraten bis zu
20 prozent im baltikum wo die wirtschaft
vergleichsweise gut läuft wir haben aber
in staaten außerhalb des euro ist in der
schweiz 3
das ist für die schweiz fiel aber im
vergleich zu deutschland frankreich oder
dem baltikum ist das inzwischen eine
vergleichsweise lächerliche inflation
das heißt überall dort wo er noch
währungspolitik für das lang betreiben
kann hat man ein bisschen mehr
handlungsspielraum man hat ähnliche
probleme weil die finanzpolitik überall
ähnliche fehler gemacht hat immer die
verschuldungsproblematik die große
immobilien pleite 2008 2009 lehman
brothers wissen wir wahrscheinlich alle
noch das sind alles ähnliche probleme
gewesen und die waren nie nur auf ein
land begrenzt die frage ist nur sind wie
europa heute mit dem hehren ziel uns
gegenüber china oder anderen märkten als
gegengewicht aufbauen zu können
überhaupt noch in der lage zu agieren
und gerade das thema investitionen hat
in deutschland jetzt schon in einem maße
abgenommen wir sind längst abgehängt von
den großen tech firmen wir sind längst
nicht mehr der weltmarktführer bei
vielen produkten die das gerne wäre dass
die familienunternehmer betrifft sind
wir immer noch weltmarktführer
jahresgehalt wache nehmen ist warum man
dem ganzen stall weil der mittelstand
funktioniert hat langer wenn wir jetzt
aus wie andere wäre ja meist
wertschöpfung und hunter ist schön und
richtig aber ohne werden schon geht's
nicht das heißt wenn wir es nicht
schaffen den mittelstand zu
stabilisieren untermain für den
mittelstand an arbeitnehmern genauso wie
den unternehmer mittelstand und das
kriegen wir nur hinrich solide
währungspolitik dann werden wir das
bisschen substanz was noch da ist ein
europaweiter verlieren und deswegen
müssen wir uns fragen wo ist die lösung
steigen wir ein in die italienischen
verhältnisse in dem wir schon drin sind
genau genommen oder gibt es eine
bundesregierung oder gibt es politiker
die sagen nein das wollen wir nicht das
ist nicht unsere gesellschaft und finanz
und wirtschaftspolitik und ich warte auf
die die sich dahin stellen ist es
offensichtlich dass ich die italienische
lösung nur so mit wehmut finde aber eins
ist auch klar weiter zu sparen und die
schwarze null anzustreben während alle
anderen das geldausgeben in europa wird
und deutschland auf einer anderen ebene
so verlierer machen das heißt entweder
sagen wir machen uns ehrlich wir machen
italienische verhältnisse und geben geld
aus den inflationieren sowie dass sich
europa jahrzehntelang getan hat oder wir
gehen einen anderen weg aber diesen weg
werden wir da nicht mit ein gemeinsam
gehen können dh de facto perspektivisch
muss es einen währungsschnitt geben und
ein teil des euro und werden sie es wird
in einige machen
zudem mag aber es wird wenn man das täte
und das wäre ein gravierender schritt
aber es wäre ein schritt der das lange
elende inflation beenden würde
irgendwann dann müsste man sich partner
suchen aber die gibt s denn es gibt
außerhalb von deutschland noch ein paar
länder in europa die unter der 60
prozent verschuldungsgrenze liegen die
wir uns eigentlich im euroraum wahl
versprochen haben aber es ist nicht die
großen länder und deutschland ist leider
auch nicht dabei